we all know the news can be a bit much
it's constant it's annoying sometimes
makes you want to do this police you
could just cruise to Canada I think
their news is just to maple leaves
rubbing together I got you girl
getting on uber and requesting you
arrive at the Canadian border they have
acts going imagine all the other things
you can learn to throw pinks later uber
makes it easy to request a ride for a
friend it doesn't have the app or
originally broke their phone in a fit a
news rage oh that's nasty you're gonna
need some universal health care for that
why not get everything checked while
you're there if I can see you're gonna
need some of that new legal herb to calm
you down
Terrence fried chicken a new national
birth you know what on it
thank you will gonna get me a Mountie
man to the airport sir head of the
camera the possibilities are endless